in some states Texas Alabama Arkansas
we are seeing families with trans kids
moving moving out moving out of the
states all together and
um this is potentially going to go in a
very very dark Direction and one of the
reasons that these bills uh are
dangerous is that they really push the
boundaries of demonizing trans people by
codifying that this is a group that's a
problem we need to pass special laws
because this group is so problematic and
this is going to expand and we know it's
going to expand because it is expanding
it used to be just about bathrooms now
it's about what are teachers allowed to
say if they don't want to get fined it's
about so many things beyond that so I'm
putting it on your radar this is all to
fix problems that really don't exist